MADE A STOCKHOLM SYNDROME.
HE FOUND HIMSELF IN THE MIDDLE
OF AN INTERNATIONAL INCIDENT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
YOU.
>> MADE THIS SHORT DOCUMENTARY.
IT WAS ABOUT IMMIGRANT CRIME IN
SWEDEN.
TUCKER CARLSON INTERVIEWED YOU
ABOUT THE FILM, TALKING ABOUT
HOW THE SWEDISH PUBLIC FEELS
ABOUT THE SITUATION, LET'S WATCH
THIS.
>> THEY KNOW THIS CRIME HAS
HAPPENED, THE STATISTICS ARE
CLEAR, THEY WOULD REFER TO, WHAT
IS THE ROOT CAUSE BEHIND IT.
AND SAY, IT'S HAPPENING MORE
VIOLENCE.
IT'S MEN WHO ARE RAPING PEOPLE,
NOT REFUGEES.
THE MAJORITY OF THE POPULATION
STILL WANTS TO HAVE AN OPEN DOOR
POLICY.
IT'S CONFOUNDING.
>> THE PRESIDENT SEES YOUR
INTERVIEW, WHICH MEANS YOU
INFLUENCED HIM.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES SPREAD.
WHICH REALLY AMOUNTS TO FALSE
INFORMATION, RIGHT?
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT BEING
PART OF THAT.
>> THE WHOLE THING IS SURREAL.
RIGHT?
>> IT WAS A SATURDAY NIGHT, I
GET A TEXT FROM SOMEBODY.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT REFERENCED
YOU, I WENT TO IT, AND SAID, I'M
NOT SURE WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT, HE'S INTIMATING THIS
INTERVIEW WE HAD WITH TUCKER,
IT'S ABSOLUTELY -- IT'S
INCREDIBLE, IT'S SURREAL, IT'S
UNFORTUNATE HE HAD THE
MISSTATEMENT, BUT IT'S BEEN ALL
GOOD FOR ME.
>> HERE'S WHAT HE SAID, LET'S
WATCH THIS.
>> WE'VE GOT TO KEEP OUR COUNTRY
SAFE.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
GERMANY.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING
LAST NIGHT IN
OVER THE PAST COUPLE YEARS,
SEVERAL DANGEROUS IMMIGRANT
RIOTS HAVE BROKEN OUT, AND
SHOOTINGS ACROSS SWEDEN HAVE
INCREASED SHARPLY.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE NUMBERS
HERE, WE LOOKED AT THE STATS
FROM THE U.S. STATE DEPARTMENT.
HERE'S WHAT WE LEARNED.
MUCH OF THE CRIME WAS
NONVIOLENT, COMPUTER FRAUD AND
VANDALISM, IN 2015, VIOLENT
CRIME DECREASED SLIGHTLY.
THERE WAS NO STAGGERING
INCREASE.
WHERE DID YOU GET YOUR
INFORMATION, AND DID YOU LOOK AT
THE OFFICIAL NUMBER?
>> FROM A FAR MORE ACCURATE
SOURCE AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
THE KEEPER OF ALL STATS FOR
SWEDEN.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT I CALL HEAVY
CRIMES, I'M TALKING ABOUT
MURDER, SEXUAL ASSAULT.
SEXUAL ASSAULT FROM 2006, 2015
IS UP ALMOST 50%, MURDER IN  20.
AND IT'S UP EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE RUDE,
THOUGH, ARE YOUR EARS AND EYES
WORKING.
THE NUMBERS AS WE'RE READING
FROM THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
THEY DON'T SHOW WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING.
>> THOSE ARE BROAD NUMBERS.
YOU HAVE.
>> I HAVE THEM, THEY'RE RIGHT
HERE.
>> THE RAW NUMBERS ARE UP.
>> SHOW ME.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT CRIME HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
OVERALL, FOR THE PAST DECADE.
>> CRIME IS DOWN.
>> RAPE IS DOWN, MURDER IS DOWN.
NOT IN SWEDEN.
>> OVER TIME, THAT'S THE SAME
THING.
>> NO.
>> IT'S NOT SKYROCKETING.
>> MURDER IS UP.
>> LET'S SAY YOU'RE RIGHT.
YOU'RE CLASSIFYING THIS AS A
SKYROCKET THAT CRIME IS
SKYROCKETING.
IT'S NOT A SKYROCKET.
>> YOU THINK WHEN RAPE IS DOWN
IN THE UNITED STATES AND
EVERYWHERE ELSE IN WESTERN
EUROPE AND RAPE IS UP 50%,
THAT'S NOT SKYROCKETING?
>> BECAUSE OF THE WAY THEY
CLASSIFY RAPES NOW.
>> THE DEFINITION WAS BEFORE
THOSE NUMBERS.
>> IF YOU ARE AT A CONCERT AND
SOMEONE TOUCHES YOU ON ANY PART
OF YOUR BODY.
THAT IS NOW RAPE IN SWEDEN.
>> IT'S SEXUAL ASSAULT IN THE
UNITED STATES, BUT IT'S NOT
SEXUAL ASSAULT IN SWEDEN.
IT'S NOW UNDER THE RAPE CLAUSE.
>> THE DEFINITION OF RAPE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
I LOOKED AT THE DEFINITION.
>> WE KNOW WHAT IT IS, WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE UNITED STATES,
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SWEDED